this is a tweet from clown world this is
what Target in San Francisco looks like
let's uh make this bigger and take a
look at this
so uh for those that can't tell in the
immediate especially for those that are
just listening every single item in the
Target is locked
you cannot take an object shampoo razors
hairspray none of it it's all behind
plexiglass and lock yep all behind
plexiglass and locked this is creepy huh
this is cultural degradation this is
moral Decay and what we were talking
about the previous segment is
you know the question of what does
society be better if what what the
United States do better if everybody was
Christian the the the actual simple way
I put it is yes but not in my view and I
you guys probably disagree because of
Christianity but because of a shared
moral Foundation that rests on
respecting each other and Society I
actually don't disagree with you I I
mean I have never felt like I am
personally uh in charge of making
everyone be religious right it works for
me and it's important part of uh making
myself be a good person but I think
generally the the point of having a
shared value system is to have a strong
Society right and I don't think the
government should make you to a church
but I do think that if you don't
understand why our rules are set up if
you don't understand the shared social
contract that we have that's based on
these ideas then you are very much
likely to not participate in society in
a way that is beneficial to your
neighbors I mean if you look at this it
makes me think about those stories have
you heard of those people who'll be like
when my grandparents went to the store
they would just like pay and then
someone would bring their groceries to
their unlocked house and put them away
for them we'd leave our doors unlocked
what are you talking about I would never
do that I would never just let some rent
but this is totally a different time
it's a time when we were a much stronger
in uh shared morality back then
everybody would meet at church on Sunday
yeah so if you broke into someone's
house are you nuts you show up to church
they're all gonna they're gonna turn at
you and they're gonna Point their
fingers at you you're ostracized so
people were like oh I I can't do that I
mean that's that's that scares me like
the the negative consequences are
massive now there's no Gatherings
there's no there's no day to spend with
your family so these people are like why
do I care if Target loses hairspray and
then the people at Target are like I
also the people who work there I also
don't care and so then you get security
guards cops and employees which is like
we literally don't care and the system
starts to break it's not just the social
contract too it's I think it's a step
further than that because it's obviously
the behavior like look at that that's
incredibly Eerie that we're at the point
in our society that that is a thing it's
also reality
like when you don't have a shared moral
fabric then you actually question what
is reality and that's where we are right
now with all of these things on on Race
on sex and gender on right and wrong on
what Justice Means all of these things
we're actually asking these existential
questions that were asked in a different
way at the beginning of our country like
what is somebody's right what is a basic
individual right what's the purpose of
government what is wrong what is what is
order we're asking all of these
questions that we haven't asked in over
250 years because we lost that moral
fabric because that was the that was the
thing that defined all of those terms
which allowed us to then build Society
on it I really think that it was this
worship of money that creeped in with
the Federal Reserve System and this
obsession with banking that happened in
like the 1500s Central Banking and stuff
because people I see them worshiping
money and it's it's a misguided love or
but if we taught the Ten Commandments
Thou shalt not covet right thou should
not come down worship false gods right
but like oh sorry to interrupting oh I'm
good there's so much value to having
resources that's that's an issue it's
not money it's just you know but I I
think a component of the component of
this is the loss of community
it's really easy to be like you don't
need government when you have charity
well yeah everybody are good moral
people who agree with each other and
then everybody's living and working and
one day they see a man whose house
burned down and he's homeless and they
say we gotta help this guy and they all
pitch in and the man shakes their hand
and then the next time a house burns
down that guy joins in to help too now
neighbors don't talk to each other that
nobody likes each other and so it's all
every man for himself and they'll loot a
grocery store they don't care right I
don't know you and philanthropic uh
participation volunteer work is has been
declining rapidly for decades in America
so we say like oh we should have
Community you know non-profits or
whatever intercede and help people but
like who is running that who is
prioritizing that uh this is still a
trend with a lot of fundraising but
typically women make a lot of uh the
majority of philanthropic giving
decisions meaning they decide where
their family's going to donate money and
that's a trend that because a lot before
women were in the workplace they also
LED their families uh efforts towards
serving the community right whether that
be through the church through nonprofits
whatever else like we have let all of
this go away because we also destroyed
the structure that was holding it
together well you know the issue is I
think you're exactly correct the the
issue is conservatives aren't good at
Art so the left makes the worst possible
interpretation of religion in government
and they make
um what's that handmaid's tale yeah and
then it's just meant to to be the most
evil interpretation of what a religious
Society is conservatives don't equally
create the inverse of the benefits or
the positives that could come with a a
shared moral Foundation
why do you think people don't like each
other
uh but there's a lot of reasons people
don't like each other some people are
just they don't like each other based on
looks I believe that's rooted in uh
tribalist fear a human who is growing up
in say the 1400s lives in a small
village of 100 200 people they know that
these people they are safe with humans
are safe around those who are part of
their Community they then see another
person with a different color skin they
immediately know this person does not
live where I live they may try to take
from me steal from me or hurt me that's
I think the root of where racism comes
from is like human natural tribal fears
well we need to overcome that because
that's not the case we're all people and
I don't think someone's race is a pretty
determinant factor in whether you can
trust them or not in fact I'm from
Chicago and I've only been mugged by
white dudes you know what I mean so like
I don't look at someone and be like I
can know everything about the person
but that's one one component one
component is
um separate moral foundations like you
think it is good to uh I don't know
let's do usury for example you come from
a society where you're like loans are
really really great it helps the you
know the systems uh Thrive and grow and
then you get some leftists who are like
usury is evil that exploits the workers
you are stealing from people now you're
at odds because of deep rooted moral
foundations so there's a lot of reasons
people hate each other right
can I add a comment yeah that your point
on Art do you know who used to be really
really good at Art and Science the
church the Catholic Church how was
Vatican 2 for you guys though I feel
like you guys gave some of it up oh yeah
that's why I said used to I think we're
reclaiming some of that like I'm sure
there's a bunch of Trad cats watching
watching your show who are like the
traditional Latin Mass who want to get
back to the beauty of that tradition the
beauty of the artwork and the cathedrals
and all of that I was just reading when
we lost some of the religiosity the
faith we lost our stronghold on on
cultural Excellence yeah the original
culture War yeah I was just reading an
article about a seminary in Cincinnati I
believe saying that they're having to
build new apartments and dorms because
they are getting Millennial men who want
to go into the priesthood after years
and years of decline I mean I think
there is a shift I think largely we've
talked about this people crave some kind
of structure and Direction you don't
actually want to be an authority in
dominated by Authority but on the other
hand people want to believe that there
is good there is evil and I think this
uh this generational shift towards queer
towards uh relationships that have fewer
structures to like I don't really think
I have to you know comply with any sort
of uh social norms at all I think that
is sort of the divisive part of the
youngest generation wokeness proves that
a lot of people crave Authority they beg
for it they want to be told what to do
and what to think and wokeness exploits
that within people some people are
leaders some people are followers and
there's no um negative to being either
some people say look I just want to work
hard I want to be a good good provide
good service to my fellow man you let me
know how I can best serve my fellow
people and that's totally fine some
people say you know what I think I can
help you better serve your neighborhood
your community and your world and those
are leaders what I'm ends up happening
is you have people who I really do think
many of them want do good easily
exploited by corrupt ideologies
but because right now you have very
liberty-minded individuals on the right
and Collective minded individuals on the
left the libertarian post post-liberal
or conservatives don't want to go to
these people and say I will tell you how
to live your life they want to say let
me give you the information to free you
and they say no I want to be told what
to do and so you're never gonna it goes
back to what I said before I know that
this is controversial even on the right
but I just don't believe that there's
any such thing as neutrality I don't
think that we can create this sort of
like even playing field this vacuum I
think something is going to fill it and
it's either going to be right or it's
going to be wrong it's either going to
be good or it's going to be evil there's
not there's not it's it the rest is just
an exercise in moral relativism but it's
it's really just right or wrong and so
if you're looking at the good of society
like we have we're so afraid as
conservatives of using the power of
government because we are limited
government-minded people right like we
don't want to have this huge big daddy
government but because of that we
actually overcompensate and we don't
take advantage of the powers and
government government that are that are
justly given to government officials by
the people so you get leftists in office
they're not worried they're they're
unconcerned with wielding their power
and yet oftentimes conservatives don't
want to do that because they're like oh
just using the power of government just
using the power of government
bureaucrats we've demonized so much when
the left does it that we don't want to
do it ourselves and I think that's
completely wrong if conservatives want
if we want an ordered Society
conservatives have to understand that
um we're going to have to fill that
vacuum with indoctrination and with with
the government a little bit or the left
is going to do it and this is a problem
I see a lot of people on the anti-woke
side they're like indoctrinations in
schools is wrong and I thought about it
I talked about this we talked we talked
about it a few months ago I'm like it
actually isn't wrong right what's wrong
is it's a bad indoctrination yeah we
absolutely do want to indoctrinate
children with American values hello
children it is good to have free speech
it is good deaf freedom of religion it
is good to have a free press it is good
to have the presumption of innocence
that's indoctrination we rely on the
parents to teach the kids so by the time
they get to the school it's not the
teacher that has to teach the kid that
it's not that good job send their kids
to school and they're like too they said
they spend like an hour a day with their
kids families even even well-intentioned
families if your kid if you put your kid
through the traditional tract of like
daycare pre-preschool whatever it's
called like TK Pre-K kindergarten like
they're fully formed by the education
system that's the problem because if the
parent isn't teaching the kids these Ten
Commandments or right and wrong or
things like that by the time they get to
school they don't know so they'll just
listen to any Authority and maybe these
people these Libertarians are like I
don't want to be that guy because I know
it's not right to take advantage of you
and if someone else is like I will don't
worry about it yeah that that's why when
it comes to the neutrality question
which I think you're correct on Ten
Commandments or Marxism I'm like man
I would much rather have the Ten
Commandments than Marxism
and I'll take it I agree that there's no
neutrality true neutral because I think
what's happening is if if it's a scale
and you've got like good and evil and
then in the middle you've got neutral
it's always moving so if it's moving so
fast between the boat that it looks like
it's in the middle because it's
oscillating so quickly so you can kind
of find a balance between good and evil
in within yourself you know we have to
kill animals to eat them that's if you
ever look an animal in the eyes before
you kill it like that's a pretty evil
thing I disagree well what if it's your
cat like I mean if you kill your cat why
would you kill you exactly you wouldn't
because you would think it would be evil
but but you could kill your cow so like
we just kind of accept that certain evil
violent then let's say like peace and
violence we have these two things and
then in the middle there's neutral and
and but it's like we're always a balance
of of both but if you can get the
balance in order then it you can kind of
seem neutral I think but you're still
both you're still going to be one or the
other at all times I I guess I look at
it a little bit differently I look look
at it as it's a constant tug of war
between good and evil and that spectrum
and so the closest the closer we can get
it to permanently being up at good then
when it does have that fluctuation it's
still not quite as bad as dipping all
the way down to evil yeah like killing a
cow's not Evil killing a cow for fun to
torture the animal is Evil killing it to
eat is not right that that's the
distinction humans have had to justify
that killing animals is okay because
that's how we survive I understand it
which makes which means it literally is
yeah it's fine to us but you know yes is
it to God God doesn't want us to do
factory farming I'll tell you that I
mean the Bible says it is
dominion over animals I asked God if he
would if it would judge me and it said
for factory farming you'll be judged I
think that's a highly biased and uh
ill-informed position maybe because you
need you need like so what I what I
would say to that is I think you've
probably seen a handful of shock content
videos that make you believe farming is
done in a certain way but before you can
make a statement like that you need to
actually go to one of these so-called
factory farms and actually investigate
for yourself whether or not that what
they've told you on the internet is true
have you seen the videos of them like
picking up the little pigs and smashing
them on the ground
is that like showing a video of a
murderer and saying all humans are
murderers well I'm just asking if you've
seen that video I've seen them and those
people I've seen the pools of blood and
feces once again I've also seen videos
of people of various races doing bad
things and I don't blame every person of
those races for the actions of an
individual showing me a video of one guy
bashing a pig does that make me think
all Farms are evil factory farms not all
farms
and what is Factory
and you could be referring to three
Farms that's my point
so you need to you need to figure out
industrialized farming where you've
where you've have you ever gone
no and that's my point and they wouldn't
let drones fly over those things instead
of taking a strong moral position on
something you haven't investigated I've
investigated it from a distance but I
haven't been one but so like I could
pull up a video where it's like the
polar bears are dying and the
environmentalists show you 100 videos of
polar bears that are gone looking but
they're lying all the time what they do
is they take a a a really old polar bear
on his deathbed which is normal take a
video of it and say this poor polar bear
is starving to death they're tricking
you that's what National Geographic did
you didn't make that up that's a real
thing that happened remember that very
popular photographing video of the gaunt
polar bear that was just an old polar
bear it was an old polar bear they knew
was dying they blamed it on climate
change but it was just like no the thing
was like aged and they don't tell you
that polar bears can swim like
ridiculously far distance they're almost
aquatic mammals my point is this I agree
with you it's bad when you see a video
of a guy torturing animals and stuff and
I blame that person for torturing
animals I don't know if if it's
indicative of all large-scale farming
it's the antibiotics that they use in
Mass they're like they'll hit things
with antibiotics but before they're sick
just so they don't get sick and then
that makes people sick that but that's
not torturing an animal that's like
that's like a human error you know what
I mean they'll have like mastitis on the
cow nipples because they suck they put
they hook them up to machines and they
just 24 7 they're just kind of I don't
know how have you ever gone to a dairy
farm
uh no I've been to like eight and I've
never seen that which ones I went
California I went to three different
ones I've been to a few well I went a
bunch throughout California I've been to
uh some in Tech I think Texas I don't
know if there's a beef that might be
beef cattle so uh We've out here the
Farms don't have any of that and we've
been to like three or four of those so
my shout out to all the organic farmers
out there but this isn't real people
don't people don't understand this like
I was confused by this when I went to
the first dairy farm ever in California
and there was no fence and the cows were
all eating and I said what if the cows
leave and the farmer goes where would
they go and I was like well I don't know
like what if they just like wander off
and he goes but where and I'm like a
random Direction and leave and he goes
but there's no food there and I'm like
are you saying cows won't leave and he
goes
yeah why would they leave the food's
right here and I was just like and he
was like you ever hear this thing until
the cows come home
cows aren't gonna go wander off and die
in the woods bro
you didn't say bro but like that's the
idea like you think cows are so dumb
they're gonna be like might as well just
go die no they're not like looking to
take a vacation
Trail and try to like build up
civilization I heard there's great
surfing if I just keep it but so uh what
he pointed out was the milking stations
the cows choose to go into because
they're uncomfortable right they build a
bunch of milk up and the cows are like
and they walk in and the Machine then
milks them and the cows walk back out
and start eating again and the one thing
I could say is probably sad or cruel is
the taking of the calf from the mother
oh my God it's brutal but I also don't
think it's evil I think
lions eat animals cats eat animals the
the world as it is as nature is is that
is it is it evil when a rabbit eats a
flower no it's destructive it's not evil
I don't think the word evil is really
even that valuable these days I I
actually wouldn't even agree that it's
destructive the rabbit eats the flower
and then turns the flower into more
rabbits that's creative it destroys the
flower to create yeah but it says
creation and destruction you know just
the flower serve its ultimate purpose by
feeding the rabbit and creating more
rabbits when people like animals
Wilt and die and then it would just go
back in the soil and actually some of
the seeds actually evolved specifically
so that through the digestion of the
animal it sprinkles the seeds around
meaning many of these plants actually do
want to be eaten
I mean fruits exist for a reason that
the plant will drop something that is
full of sugar so that something will eat
it and carry its seeds and help it
propagate
yeah man I'm concerned with factory
farming High use of antibiotics feces
and blood contaminating the environment
I I get all of that secrecy but I think
I'm concerned that's propaganda I'm with
you on the antibiotic overuse I think
that there's been a lot of there's been
a lot of studies we were talking about
this before we went on air I'm pretty
I'm pretty based on on big food and big
Pharma and I think our overuse our
society's overuse of antibiotics is like
wrecked our guts and caused a lot of
chronic health conditions and that
because there's incredible profit
motivative on both sides like from big
food and then big Pharma to like
circulate this like problem solution
problem solution like I agree with you
on that thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time